ich begrüße sie alle hier diesen
seminaren reform des moralischen und
heute geht es um etwas anderes als mit
simulierten das mehr ein wundes gesagt
hat mir heute gibt es historisches über
thom entlaste und es geht auch noch
wegen die zeit leicht und diese gegend
sinken
und ich denke dass ins container
wasserstand ist man weiß jetzt auf den
ersten blick meinen augen funktioniert
ist und das war wie eine heutige sitzung
bis sich besser kennen lernen was es
genau damit auf sich hat und ich sehe
hier gerade die haben ein zu schauen
das ist eigenwillig geben uns ein
leibchen ok als amerikanischen gut und
ich möchte zum einstieg möchte ich sie
so ein bisschen heranführen an diese
thematik und zwar möchte ich nun
deutlich 7 support sünden wie sie
sohn verankert sind wir mal kurz
präsentiert zwischenzeitlich sehr gut
also wir haben hier weil man sieht mich
gar nicht gehen und es ist auch nicht
schlimm heute nicht warum mir schon okay
also jetzt sieben und sie haben jetzt
hier hochmut serbia lateinisch dann
haben wir hier das ist die erzieherin
und da haben wir die neid wie ihr haben
wir zorn ist haben wir die wollust ist
die furia
[Musik]
wir haben zum schluss dass die track hat
und wir wollen jetzt also merken sich
die mal gut diese sieben sogenannten und
wir werden ihn jetzt gleich diese codes
endlich mal wieder ein bisschen bild
licht veranschaulicht uns bis sie wieder
anschieben
das ist jetzt offiziell dann folgen wie
sie drei 10 verankert ist so dass die
schlimmsten sie jetzt also hoch ist und
chips nach dieser traditionellen
auflisten und wir wollen jetzt folgendes
machen also die könnte ich mal ein
bisschen erscheinen das ist so die
zutaten und wir wollen jetzt hall jetzt
machen melden sich immer in die 7
und wir ziemlich arbeitsauftrag an sie
dazu folgendes welche der sieben
todsünden wird gleich auf den bildern
eingefangen
diesen bildern sitzt
bekämpfung kommt wie ich diese sieben
wirklichen präsentieren
während dargestellt von den siegen dinge
geworden haben sie doch mal an seiner
verschiedenen scheibe auf und so klein
ist ein test für sie das können sie in
partnerarbeit machen würde ich mal
vorschlag also die fragen sind wir hier
sind benannt werden geht es gleich in
der folge bildlich dargestellt wir
finden es die gleise gestellt ist sünde
normativ problematisch da werden sie
jetzt gefragt und soll man sich
überlegen warum ist es jetzt gerade
touristen
also was ist daran so problematisch
station
das geht natürlich wieder mit der wir
sind alle zusammen wie die wahrzunehmen
da stehen wahrscheinlich darum was ein
bisschen details wenn es nicht gut genug
lesbar ist müssen sich ein bisschen nach
vorne es dürfen gerne auch auf twitter
folgen müssen sich schon wieder raus das
warum ist die dargestellte sind
problematisch sie sehen das bild
natürlich noch größer und besser wenn
sie online sind weil dann können sie
denn es läuft auf der höchsten auflösung
1080i oft ist das heißt wenn sie es
jetzt im tablet oder smartphone
versichern können sie das bild direkt
voraus ich brauche gar nicht aus
wir haben schon drei likes das ist sehr
gut so ne also mathematisch normativ
bedeutet das sind die ansprüche des
anstoßes die der tradition wohl in den
sinn
anstoß das verletzt unsere moral
vielleicht auch religion justiz gehen
sie müssen wir denken 7000 theologischen
sind keine moralischen katholischer
hintergrund aber es hat natürlich auch
moralischen die moralische dimension
aber es ist eine mischung bewahren und
die treten arbeitsauftrag die mich gerne
an sie teilen möchte ist der welche
dieser jugendlichen für schlecht halten
sie für die schlimmste und sie jetzt
persönlich und es im team
also warum währungsraums moralischen sie
können auch theologische der endlösung
gründe anführen aber ich werde jetzt
erstmal vorschlag gebe es mal so
moralische gründe sehe ich diese sieben
sünden die jetzt der marktmacht
betrachten halten sie geschnitzt als sie
persönlich und zuhause welchen gründen
die tradition des nächsten sie die hatte
den hut
erste stimmen zu hören ist für die stadt
zu und schauen sie einfach mal die
schönste ist
und das sollten sie jetzt viel mehr
gegen st ich zeige ihnen jetzt ein
nachspiel
und sie dürfen dann so ein bisschen
mitdiskutieren und auch gerne
[Musik]
anscheinend gut sehen können aber wir
hatten das der letzten sitzung auch
schon gesprochen
diese sieht macht sich dann überlegen
sie mal welche diesen todsünden hier
bildlich darstellen das hat mir zu
beginn der letzten sitzung bis aktiviert
wenn sie es noch steht auch drin wenn
sie gut lesen können hier steht es wie
man sich nicht so gut aufgelöst
genau das ist der geilste würde die
haben zinsen gibt es möglichkeiten
darüber diskutiert sie sehen die details
hier schießen aus tröpfelt und die
schere abgeschnitten
bregenz im wald also das hat uns ein
bisschen den eindruck als wolle jeder zu
das geld an sich ziehen zusammen und
jetzt belegt mal was könnte jetzt
problematisch seien an den geiz ist das
moralisch warum kann man diese frage ist
was es ist eine charaktereigenschaft
ehrgeiz müssen uns auch mal fragen was
würde ich sagen ganz was ist das dass
das laster ist es ein und trugen ist das
charakter geschaffen ist
die handlungsmaximen als prinz kommt
dass wir ihm sagen dass es keine zahl
der installationen
ja das ist eine haltung diesen trick
ja man erhalte bis gut
genau sie haben jetzt schon den
aristoteles etwas vorweggenommen wir
kommen auch die auch sie haben jetzt da
hast du noch gar nicht kann haben es
automatisch richtig machen das eben
gesagt es geht darum den mädchen nehmen
finden mussten
der guide ist zu einer ja eine eine der
beiden seiten die wir vereint sind und
soll ins welche das geil
das ist eine problematische
kennenzulernen sollte man schon wissen
lassen
[Musik]
ok also angst dass man nicht bereit ist
kommunizieren dass nämlich bereit ist
auch mittel malz investieren so etwas
also gut entwickeln mehr ganz so
ängstlich ist nur kurzfristig denkt und
sich nicht getraut weil so dass sie eine
gewisse summe auch mal in andere leute
zu investieren wenn alles an die strafen
müssen
ach so ok darum haben wir kick
[Musik]
kurzmann beispiel onkel sie kennt war ja
auch an chris kolonko bertone dann
daraus gemacht unter dem weißen haus
da geht es wohl eher glauben noch der
geizige gibt es ist ein topos in der
ganzen kulturgeschichte man bringt die
gesellschaft auch persönliche bindet man
bringt man durcheinander schadet auch
die anderen das ist auch schon alles
nicht nur das was einen selbst betrifft
sieht über die zwei seien es gibt die
sich die einzigen akteure betrieb und da
hatten sie etwas dazu gesagt das ist
wohl das neben einem tief die angst
unbedingt das ist die akteure
theoretisch ist sich zeigen jetzt mal
und dann gibt es auch immer noch dass
die opfer zentrierte sich also die
energie angehen geizig gehandelt wird
der in einigen
und wenn er etwas gerne hätte oder auch
verdient oder sie verdient etwas aber er
bekommt es nicht aufkommt diese
charaktereigenschaft sind
[Musik]
dieser historische details
möglicherweise
auch einmal
gut
[Musik]
was jetzt gemacht haben wenn ich sie
recht verstanden hat ist sie haben jetzt
eine dieser tod sind auch ein bisschen
zurückgezogen haufen anzutreten
die meisten empfänden es wurden
einfach sagen dass ihm geiz auch schon
so ein bisschen geholfen eine andere
andere anderen 7 die sind jetzt ich sage
nicht ganz system voneinander sondern
die hängen auch auf gewisse weise
miteinander zusammen das hat mir selbst
zu sehen
richtig gesehen
da ist diese eine umschuldung enthalten
also lüge ist im paket enthalten
täuschung ist im plagiat enthalten auch
so ein bisschen was ich trage ist nicht
die anderen den anderen als autor
anzuerkennen ich möchte an selbst mir zu
schreiben
also zieht ihr ganz wenig bereits in
anderen autor nennen wenn der gedanke
ist
[Musik]
begeistert
wird es auch dann
ja
und findet beides will beides richtig
wichtig sei aber auch dass man bescheid
wissen
aber bin nicht kritisch hat aber wie c&a
dieses bedeutungs sprechen von 32 ist
aber das gut als unterschied in weiß und
wenn sie jetzt diesen unterschied haben
was hätten sie schon
moralisches gehabt sie unterstrichen es
finden sich immer warum ok gutes
argument die habgier alltäglichkeiten
das hat kein ende das ist wieso noch wo
alles eingetroffen
man kann ich in salzburg was würde für
guide sprechen ja
selbst halten
ich denke ja
ja
als sie zum beispiel kann ich mir eine
person vorstellen
die haptik ist und die aber dennoch
nicht ganz das was fast gar nicht mehr
vorstellen also die dennoch in ihrem
bereich dann großzügig ist aber dennoch
extrem viele werte anhäufen nicht
es ist durchaus möglich also man kann da
vielleicht in der untoten der habgier
dortmund gewisse tugenden kultivieren so
die können uns im schatten noch gedacht
[Musik]
oder verschwendung ist der kommilitonen
hatte vorhin gesagt man muss damit
finden oder zu große freizügigkeit
geschenke machen verschwinden und so
weiter
also sie sehen es ist gespannt wie sich
die verschiedenen formen des
unmoralischen unter lastet zueinander
verhalten
da kann man ganz ganz verschiedene
beziehungen
[Musik]
und sie nicht bereit seien zu zahlen das
ist
[Musik]
sie haben mich hier auf eine aktuelle
kommt jetzt hingewiesen die so aktuell
gar nicht
[Musik]
geiz ist geil wer hat diese media markt
saturn gehören das zusammen aber es war
der saturn ist so ungefähr vor zehn
jahren gab es 2007 ohne gab es im
aufkleber diesen geist ist geil
also es gab dann so ganz verschiedene
folge parodie sie rungen haben die in
dieser kampagne ja es ist jetzt ganz
geil was angst und ist davon handeln
ganz die rede
[Musik]
auf dem könnte das was man ja das
gleiche gemacht
[Musik]
oder denken sie mal fragen wie können
jetzt jemand sagen der total auf dem
smart fährt und ich nehme mich da auch
nicht ganz aus also teilweise wie könnte
man sich jetzt erreicht hat sagt ich
verstehe ja geiz ist geil in dieser
hinsicht könnte das recht werden jetzt
ein moralisches moralische grund dafür
geben dass es ist ein hobby von vielen
menschen ist es auch irgendwie passt es
seien die kosten und ich will dieses
produkt am günstigsten bekommen hier
habe ich noch offen
es gibt zum beispiel internet sei und
ein kind diesen tagesangebot die während
des chats und da geht es nach temperatur
ganze dann wurden wenn das
das produkt war es da kein angebot zu
1000 grad ziemlich gut
liga bis 2000 karten diese nur begrenzt
angeboten
und wie man da dieses produkt also
niemand haben wollte oder man wird auch
darauf hingewiesen dass köln nicht
eigentlich wollte dann kauft man so will
man dann eine stunde später noch ist
jetzt an die wohnung für dieselben
kinder hat muss er wieder abbestellen
muss weil das hat so ein bisschen was
auch ein clever netteste was du trinkst
also geils oder wie man das in diesem
sinne primitive einstellungen ist
sondern man kann es auch so wie onkel
dagobert ebner onkel dagobert der ist
die richtung dass tag leben und man
liest die geschichte gern wenn man ist
nicht ich glaube also ich glaube die
allerwenigsten gewährt und onkel
dagobert finde ich cool jedes angebot
ist nicht einfach sympathische zu
bezahlen kann
aber man kann natürlich auch gern auf
seine weise kultivieren seitlich erfasst
das wird aber da gibt es spiel auch als
geiz ist nicht gleich der 1 und ich
greife finde auch inhalt
diesen sind verstehen die onkel dagobert
kann gekauft sind mit wo es entwicklern
ins geschäftsleben schwierig ihn dann
dem mann auch andere nichts könne also
nicht bereit ist zum beispiel auch einen
fairen preis ist es aus ich möchte
eigentlich ist es moralisch geboten
einen fairen preis zu zahlen
was ist ein fairer preis also könnte
jetzt wieder darum steht was er sagen
wer diesmal der leiste forschung der
ausbeutung von arbeitern nur und dumping
der vernachlässigt umweltaspekte wir
bleiben ganz viele menschlichen
qualitäten auf der strecke wenn man das
aber sie müsste man den mauer hinschauen
also im nächsten mai nicht mehr
kandidieren anderes als wenn man trägt
das dazu bei dass jeder die
bestmöglichst die qualität zum
bestmöglichen preis verkaufen das ist
geboten
das belebt die konkurrenz das animiert
uns dazu noch bessere noch günstiger zu
machen
aber das wird schon immer
ist was auch an
das klima der gibt nicht gerne
das 100
da wird jetzt sage ich hab auch und ganz
wenig und ist
das
ich sage ich dann muss man
interpretieren die mit seinem dritten
lebensjahr wenn so eine person wie sie
sie geschildert haben denn mal eine
situation kommt dass ihr einen
dienstleistung gebracht wird und dass
ein spieler und gibt der bezahlung und
die personen immer nur das minimale gibt
dann könnte man sagen dann fehlte auch
um wertschätzung
es gibt manchmal in antiquariaten so
auflösungs verkäufen wurde an jedem
selbst überlassen sie viel öfter des
buches bezahlt und ja was macht man
nimmt man zehn seiten
man wird auch nicht den wirklichen
betrag bezahlen wenn man wird sagen gut
ist muss er reiz haben muss einen sinn
wenn man dann eben nur ein europa gibt
ja ein schnäppchen aber man fühlt sich
wohl dabei
weil man irgendeinen anderem auch nicht
schaden könnte sich fair sind nicht
recht es ist an genießen
sie sehen ich will deine freunde sein es
gibt ja immer spieler also man muss sich
genau darüber klar werden was ist damit
gemeint unterscheiden geils habgier in
welcher hinsicht betrifft setzen die
akteure auch in der suppe und dann ja
und wird er mich auch motiviert durch
andere gründe die vielleicht für
entsprechen als man muss deswegen
abknöpfen verschieden seiten
[Musik]
und dann
da es gegenüber
ja
[Musik]
ja also sei es soll ich richtig das ist
wirklich die markierung die sind nicht
eindruck und sie hat immer den aktuellen
und auch immer ein gewisses gegenüber
angeben gehandelt wird und manchmal eben
auch in einer weise die nicht wenn sie
noch eine weile zu grants sind es gehen
wir mal weiter wir haben noch ein paar
folgendes ist passiert sie gerade ich
habe vier likes ein dislike sie dürfen
wir das doch nicht so geizig sein
[Musik]
das hatten wir noch nicht
das hatten wir schon mal ja genau also
hier stopfen sich leute voll wird wie
gegessen hier kleinsten als unmäßigkeit
ja ich hatte glaube ich jetzt mal gesagt
oktoberfest vielleicht auf einem anderen
bild dieses wort oktoberfest bekommen
bestimmt noch ein dislike gleich was ist
jetzt seinen schülern
ja
gut
[Musik]
gut also gut ich sagen dass es auch mit
dem geiz ein bisschen mit der haarpflege
franzis am ende alles nicht vollkommen
alles an sich reißen und was ist noch
drin
ist ja auch möglichkeit ja also das man
nur an sich denkt ja
gut ja genau
gut dass ich darauf hinweisen die
trägheit kommt also eine
ungerechtigkeiten ziel war ich der beste
begriffe diese typen die hier genannt
wird wenn man übertreibt das exzessive
wobei die lust auf die kommen noch hätte
mir natürlich auch aber hier geht es
eine maßlosigkeit die aber dann doch
auch auf das essen häufig auch hier
bezogen
was würde ich dazu sagen ist das ist das
wirklich so schlimm was da steht
[Musik]
gut
ja
volvo ist es ja gut ging also dass man
selbst mir subjekt perspektive dass man
selbst aus dem gleichgewicht kommt die
wir gleich noch mehr hören kann man an
zu schaden
sie hatten argument gebracht dass man
dass die andere ganz wenig haben ja ja
ja
[Musik]
gut und ich glaube ein weiterer als
beckham 34 könnte diese kontrollverlust
also werden kann viel trinkt und eben
viel trinkt der verriet selbstkontrolle
und man weiß eben nicht man dank diesen
zustand will jemand anderem auch schaden
könnte man wird nicht mehr zurecht
paradies man lässt sich zu gehen
überlegen sie sich wie gesagt nebenbei
immer auch noch welche dieser situation
für sie die schlimmste passiert bayern
haben
[Musik]
nachstellen können die augen
ja gut und das ist ein wichtiger punkt
den sie ansprechen beiden die weitere
frage die ich gerne heute noch klären
sie riskieren würde wir die was ist
zuerst bis wir es die jugend da von
deren abgewichen wird durch die beiden
extreme die gängigste oder ist es nicht
anders
der fall dass wir erst gründe also in
beiden extrem formen und dann im
durchgang durch die untugenden es mit
finden müssen und nicht fragen sondern
sparen also haben wir es die crew und
die vielleicht ist natürlich gegeben
dass wir immer und wir kommen damit zum
laster wenn wir eben aus dem
gleichgewicht fall wurde müssen wir uns
nicht auf die andere weise erst durch
diese ausbildung dieses gesunkenes nicht
so gut finden weil wir sie nicht nur
matrosen ja und die folge wollte würde
ich gerne am ende mit ihnen erklärt
danach nach die wir alle bestochen haben
andreas du müssen haben sie doch fast
immer sich kein verein total nicht wo
dann geht es jetzt weiter
ich glaube jetzt kommen so langsam den
haben wir auch schon gehabt denn am
aufschlag der installer zusammen
ja genau die die sieht ja hier ist eben
sehr sehr typisch dieses diese paarung
im bett geschoben
die schnecke im haar stecken sogar
gesehen trägt hängt auch wieder so ein
bisschen mit dem vorherigen zusammen
passen sich gehen lässt
ich sehe jetzt hier nicht das was
gegessen wird auch die gäste würde
passieren gemacht aber das sind
natürlich nicht mehr ist da ist sogar
nicht mehr in der lage dazu zur völlerei
als in der trägheit ist man nicht mehr
in der situation umwelt sich sein zu
können wenn man spaß an diesen tagen
scheinen diejenigen die universität und
sich daher alles mögliche reinstopfen
geben kann man jedenfalls nicht
vorwerfen dass sie träge ist er aktiv im
konsumieren
schauen sie auch das essen das ist
wirklich eine zelebration gar nicht so
selten im leben hat er auch mit diesem
kulturellen meistens liege ich wieder
ein dislike jetzt habe ich sieben alles
leben hat sich sehr gut entwickelt
also aber wenn sie das sehen als ich
hier ist es gar keine aktivität und das
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen gegen
faulheit passivität
was ist denn jetzt ihrer problematischen
[Musik]
es gibt ein buch das lob der faulheit
gut gut
ja genau wann wird der verantwortung
nicht gerecht
aus dem biologischen kontext dieses
gebot sich zu vermehren
auch die erde zu bebauen oder mit den
pfunden zu wuchern geht eben diese
theologische quote die glaube und allen
religiosität dass man etwas macht aus
seinem leben das wird hier eben nicht
die gabe die man als theologisch
bekommen könnte die wird einfach so
hingenommen und nicht genutzt habe ich
eine frau ein kommentar in dem auf
youtube möglich war ist für dabei auch
schlecht weil man pflichten gegen sich
selbst vernachlässigt und damit sich
selbst schaden für den bruder punkt
pflichten gegen sich selbst das ist
natürlich jetzt ein neuer begriff dann
hat er nicht nur glichen glück mit
anderen könnte man sagen zu nehmen auch
gegenüber sich selbst und wie inwiefern
schadet man sich selbst wenn man der
völlerei anhängt weil man eben wieder
aus der kontrolle kommt den kontrollen
zustand von mir scheint dass also die
sozialisten jeder auf dem gleichen
kommen dass die am besten kontrollierten
zustand zweier kleiner kinder melden
ja
ja genau also die natur die man man hat
sich ja nicht selbst erschaffen mit der
schlecht haushaltet haus hält dann kann
das durchaus auch ein zeichen dafür sein
dass man generell zur schöpfung zu
ganzen welt eben einen unkontrollierten
weltens stehen werden mehrere meldung
ist nachher
[Musik]
gut als sie blumen sagen die trägheit
bedeutet dass man nicht möchte sind dass
man sich einfach gehen lässt und sich
dem schicksal ergibt sich als praktisch
dass man auf seine freiheit verzichten
das wir nicht mehr nicht mehr autonom
handelt kann der autonome person mehr
ist sondern sich selbst etwas so gehen
lässt genau hier ja gut
[Musik]
gut das mag an die kommilitonen
kommentieren
antwort schon und wie ich es dir dachten
sie jetzt besonders
ja ich weiß es gar nicht es gab es eine
art käfer mit diesen führern und her hat
er noch so eine krücke glaube ich
genauso ist glaube ich die dame die
schläft hier an dem die lebens hier an
dem lesen an und die schnecken die
langen schwimmen die mindestanlage das
hinweg zu helfen wollte
das ist ja der fdp bauen
der ist eben mich aktiv sind derweil hat
die aktion gezogen die baumstruktur frei
aber das ist ein guter hinweis warnung
kommen hier solche touren
ich glaube ihm zwei funktionen es gibt
einmal wie im fall des esels einfach so
eine eigenschaft die man ihm
natürlicherweise kulturell zugeschrieben
hatte diesen stürmischen ist regel muss
man ihres antreiben das tun und dann
haben wir aber auch noch diese tiere im
sinne dieser mystischen fabelwesen die
bedeutung glaube ich den singles
unterstreichen wir gleichen weiterbilden
siemens wird es ein bisschen extremer
forciert diese tiere gerade es geradezu
diese und ohne diese sünde die dort
angesprochen wird
die sind ja ziemlich aktiv und jetzt
haben sich fragen warum sie dadurch
fabelwesen überhaupt trinken was haben
sie da nicht dienen
im sinne der verstärkung dieser
[Musik]
haben wir einmal schauen
gegeben
ich denke es sicherlich das aber ich
glaube da kommt noch ein bisschen mehr
internationale hinein
die tiere gelten dass wir meine these
aber ich darf nicht übersehen
die tiere gelten sagen als zusätzliche
verkörperungen dieser als mit als
allegorie als allegorische figuren
dieser und jugend in dem sie die noch
forcieren geben sie noch weiter
unterstreicht des reitens
[Musik]
das ist ein glück ich hatte sie
übersehen
[Musik]
also man könnte dürfte eigentlich dir
diese toten gar nicht vorbei eigentlich
sind um schulden oder anders gesagt sie
sind in der regel nicht frei moralisch
zurechenbarkeit zur verantwortung zu
ziehen weil sie nicht aus überlegungen
heraus aus einem willensentschluss jetzt
etwas überhaupt moralisches tun können
werken tradition
das mag vielleicht besonders
intelligente delfina geben tendenziell
in der lage sind muss man offen sein
aber in der regel eigentlich nicht
[Musik]
gut genau also etwas nicht menschliches
genau
[Musik]
also die tiere dann nicht als tier
genommen sind hier als verkörperung
einer menschlichen lasterhaftigkeit als
menschliche triebe ist immer sehr tier
steht wie für den menschen für bestimmte
eigenschaften des menschen
hierzu möchten wir genießen man kann es
nicht immer ganz genauen details sehen
aber es gibt jetzt noch ein paar weitere
weitere bilder wo man die tiere noch
wichtigere rolle in ärmlichen kommentar
eine träge person kann ihre moralischen
pflichten nicht nachkommen und schadet
damit der gesellschaft und hindert sich
selbst an der entwicklung seiner
moralischen also sicherlich ja man wird
zum zuschauer und man übernehme keine
verantwortung mehr tragen müssen
man trägt nicht dazu bei die wehr jetzt
verbessern oder voranzukommen am
fortschritt man rezipiert und man ist so
der zuschauer
und wer ist die anderen erklärt anderen
müssen schon richten und dann noch eins
die trägheit im koran schlechten
personen aber auch positiv zu werten und
sans normale schlechte person denn die
träge ist das ist positiv die
gesellschaft ja ja
ja man kann sie jetzt natürlich fragen
gibt es überhaupt moralisch schlechte
personen also das zweite interessante
weise angesprochen sind das die wir auch
behandeln wollen oder ist es nicht doch
so dass die person erst mal so neutrales
und das eben nur verschiedene
charaktereigenschaften hat die sie
ablegen kann oder eben auch wechseln
kann ja noch
[Musik]
oder ist vielleicht trägt vielleicht
persönlichkeit
ja
mal
[Musik]
ok naja ich verstehen um sich das leben
zu erleichtern
also aus dieser motivation heraus in
diesen bequemlichkeit werden wir jetzt
auch aktiv um ihm wieder diesen zustand
zurückfallen zu können das nicht
[Musik]
ja das ist die frage ob ihm die frage
ist die ob aus und trugen den lastern ob
daraus etwas gutes überhaupt nicht
springen kann kann aus einer als ein
laster unbeabsichtigt etwas gutes ist
die frage
ich bin da eher skeptisch aber
[Musik]
also das müssen erstmal noch offen
lassen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob außen
pflaster aber dass der faulheit daraus
dann nicht doch vielleicht ein ansporn
folgen kann eben sich arbeit zu
erleichtern zu entlasten von gewissen
arbeiten wieder kreative ich weiß jetzt
haben wir hier ein weitere meldungen
digital die thematik erinnert mich an
der us-boys gemälde der lust das geht
zwar nicht richtige richtung das ist
peter beucke passieren haben wir glauben
auch ein niederländer das also
niederländer und diese ganzen sieben
todsünden die familie präsentieren
dieses stammen aus der mitte des 16
jahrhunderts 1540 30
das sind wahrscheinlich volksstück
holzschnitte oder kupferstich ich bin
mir nicht sicher aber es ist sehr sehr
detailliert jedenfalls gezeigt und jetzt
wird es spannend was haben wir denn
jetzt hier jetzt kommt etwas neues
ja
wie kommen sie darauf gut gut aber
schauen sie mal auf die tiere
das haben sie richtig gesagt aber
schauen sie noch die tiere gibt es ein
tier das sind jetzt richtig was macht
die frau zeit auf dem feld
[Musik]
sie vielleicht neidisch auf den baum
eigentlich schon
[Musik]
also ich habe er hat jetzt gleich dazu
aber irgendwie schlägt ja doch ein rad
oder oder also irgendwie wirft er sich
charlie sheen hat ihr so dass die frauen
heilig ist auf diese schöne feder
gewarnt die das tier hat so
interpretiere ich sagen kann dass andere
anlässe gibt sonst noch neues
gut ja
[Musik]
jahrhundert passt aber
das können
ja ja ein wohlgenährter der ein schönes
gefühl gehabt auch uns einige oder sie
finden es schon schöner als hässlich ist
es jetzt nicht
oder dieses viele geld leiht und
offensichtlich schlägt gerade der stelle
des august präsentiert und ist auch ein
bisschen geschwächt von stolz geschäft
dieser dieser hals schwillt dieser kann
der ein schädel ist so ein bisschen auch
stolz dieses ist er stolz ein bisschen
an also stolz als drin mit gerade mal
schauen was uns noch gibt ja
[Musik]
ja hier
okay gut ja ja das ist gut es geht
glaube ich in die richtige richtung
hier bremst dann plötzlich noch drin
auch hier wieder dieser typischen
gesehen hat er sich ausgesucht die er
sich davon schließen möchte ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher was genau ist ach ja
und schauen sie doch mal diese diese
blätter das ist verbaut
ja also und was ich jetzt am leid immer
dass wir insbesondere spannung also bei
trägheit wäre ich mir nicht so ganz
sicher was da so problematisch sein soll
ich es gibt gründe habe ich finde jetzt
die mite besonders stand warum könnte
dann eine besondere schließen
gut
[Musik]
ja gewinnen ja
st
gut
[Musik]
so ein bisschen zu kehren doch
vielleicht angeben aber es aus dass die
ezb also anmaßen
[Musik]
sehr gut ja gut ich muss mal ganz guten
weg sind sie gerade weiter
sie haben ja noch ein bisschen weiter
ist